So let's take a look at the code for
the updated query. So here's the query I had from
before, I just comment it out, so we can
keep it parked. But, here's the query where we get
all the conferences, and then we filter by city
equals Tokyo. To get conferences where there are more than
zero, but less than ten seats available, we need
to add two inequality filters for seats available. It's okay
to do that. You can't have inequality filters for
more than one property in a single query. But you
can have multiple inequality filters for the same property. So
first we filter for seats available greater than zero. And
then we filter again for seats available, less than
ten. Since we to add sort orders we must first
sort on seats available, because that's a property with the
inequality filters. Then we can add other sort orders for
name, and for month. If we weren't doing any sorting
at all, we could just leave off all the calls
to order. You only need to make sure the sort
order for the property with the inequality filter comes first, if
you're sorting results at all. And again, if you wanted
to go ahead and actually test this, you're going to need
to make sure that you've got some conferences that are
in Tokyo with between zero and nine seats available inclusive. Actually
I guess that's not that difficult a
criteria. Conferences in Tokyo with five seats available.